Guten Abend.
Einmal das Guten Abend.
Mein Name ist Yujal. Ich bin heute den Shaben der Arzt.
Und würde ich gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschrieb führen.
Sind Sie ein Verstanden?
Ja, gerne.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Boris Becker.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Nachname bestabieren?
Nein, mit einem mehr.
Bertha Otto Richard, Ida Siegfried.
Ja, Siegfried Boris.
So ähnlich wie Boris Becker,
Bumbumb Becker, der Tennisspieler.
Ja, okay.
Sie haben einen Namen.
Ok, Herr Becker.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Becker?
Ich bin 52 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am ersten 10.09 70.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1181 cm bin ich groß.
Wie viele wiegeln Sie bitte?
86 Kilogramm.
Und die Hörbikas, was führt sie zu uns?
Folgendes.
Und zwar seit drei Wochen habe ich Rückkünftschmerzen in meiner Lendenwirbelsohne und seit einer Woche hat es deutlich zugenommen.
Es hat langsam angefangen und ich habe halt gedacht, es geht weg, aber seit einer Woche habe ich stärkere Rückkünftschmerzen, zunehmende Rückkünftschmerzen.
Sind die Schmerzen auf rechts oder links Seite aufgetreten?
Nee, das ist so zentral.
Ich kann nicht sagen, ob rechts oder links ist.
Aber in London Bereich?
Ja, in den Lendenwirbelsäulen. Ich würde sagen beide Seiten, so in der Mitte.
Okay, Hörbiker, wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala von eins bis zehn, wobei eins ist, eins sehr leichter und zehn sehr stark dann Schmerzen verspricht?
Ja, ich würde sagen so acht.
Ja, das ist sehr hoch.
Haben Sie etwas dagegen eingenommen?
Ja, ich habe bis jetzt Ibu eingenommen, Ibu Profen 800 mg, die nehme ich seit drei, vier Tagen, drei Mal am Tag ein.
Hat das Ihnen geholfen?
Ein bisschen.
Eine leichte Linderung habe ich davon im Schlechtblut.
Aber ich habe trotzdem noch Schmerzen, aber es ist nicht weggegangen, es ist nicht weniger geworden.
Nur wenn ich das einnehme habe, ist dann ein paar Stunden Ruhe und dann geht es wieder los.
Sind die Schmerzen in anderen Körperregionen aus?
Nein, das ist so lokal der Schmerz.
Haben Sie Taubheitsgefühl oder Kribbeln?
Wo?
Irgendwo in den Beinen oder?
Den Rupfen habe ich nicht.
Wie ist es, wenn man sich die Schmerzen an der Schmerzen schmiert?
Wie sind die Schmerzen am Anfang auch getreten?
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt, was die Schmerzen auslösen konnten?
Nein, würde ich nicht so sagen.
Von Tag zu Tag habe ich es schon aufgetragen.
Ich bin morgens aufgestanden und hatte ein bisschen Schmerzen.
Die kamen und gehen die ersten zwei Wochen.
Seit einer Woche ist es so, dass es dann nicht stärker geblieben sind und zugenommen haben.
Ich bin nicht hingefallen, aber ich habe nichts Schweres getragen.
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, was es auslösen könnte.
Sind die Schmerzen immer da oder treten die Schmerzen nur hin und wieder auf?
Seit einer Woche sind sie immer da, stetig da.
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt, was die Schmerzen verliehen werden?
Ich habe es verschlimmert, wenn ich mich hinsetze, habe ich mehr Schmerzen.
Ich muss mich wieder hinlegen oder stehen.
Wenn ich mich beuge, dann nehme ich es mehr zu der Schmerz.
Haben Sie eine Kraftmusik oder eine Lärmung in der Extremität oder in Muskeln?
Nein, ich habe keine Kraftmusik bemerkt.
Haben Sie noch Begleiter in der Stülpfrost?
Wie zum Beispiel. Was beiden Sie damit?
Haben Sie Fieberstülpfrost?
Ich habe nicht mehr Fieberstülpfrost.
Haben Sie in nächster Zeit nicht gewünscht, abgenommen oder zugegenommen?
Nein, ich habe es ungefähr gleich gewünscht seit Jahren.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit der Stulgang?
Nein, aber nicht.
Ist Ihnen übel oder schwindelig?
Nein, das ist nicht.
Haben Sie Krönchen, die sich in der Stilpfrost verweigern?
Nein, das ist nur Bluthochdruck.
Seit wann haben Sie Bluthochdruck?
Seit fünf Jahren.
Nehmen Sie dagegen Medikamente ein?
Ja, dann nehme ich Bram-Mepril ein.
Morgen eine Tablette.
Wie viel Minigramm?
25 Minigramm.
Ich habe noch eine Tablette.
Haben Sie noch andere für die Krönchen?
Nein, das ist nicht so.
Nehmen Sie aus der Bram-Mepril regelmäßige Medikamente ein?
Nein, ich habe es nicht.
Ist bei Ihnen eine Allergie bekannt?
Ich habe eine Allergie gegen eine Penicillin.
Wie hat Sie die Allergie gemacht?
Ich hatte damals Atemnot, wo ich es bekam.
Atemnot konnte schlecht atmen.
Also, schlecht atmen.
Haben Sie noch andere Allergie?
Nein, ich habe keine Allergie.
Unverträglichkeit habe ich, wenn ich die Klopfernak nehme.
Wenn ich das einnehme, dann kriege ich Durchfall.
Das kann ich nicht vertragen.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Ja, zweimal.
Mit 15 Jahren hatte ich eine Blinddarmentfernung.
Damals habe ich auch die Allergie bekommen.
Sie hatten damals eine Penicillin gegeben.
Seitdem habe ich es bekannt mit der Allergie.
Das andere Mal war ich 28 Jahre alt.
Da hatte ich einen Fahrradunfall.
Ich habe einen Handgelenk gebrochen.
Das wurde operiert mit einer Platte und Schraube.
Angegern wurde das ausgenommen.
Ein Handgelenk gebrochen?
Ja, ein Distalleradius war gebrochen.
Wie wurde diese Gebrochen behandelt?
Operativ musste das gerichtet werden.
Man hat es mit Platte und Schrauben stabilisiert.
Gut, Herr Becker.
Ist Ihrer Familie bestimmte für Erkrankungen wichtig?
Mein Vater hat Bluthochdruckerkrankungen.
Meine Mutter hatte eine Erkrankung.
Sie musste in Solinen nehmen.
Wie viele Jahre hat Ihre Mutter seit längerer Zeit?
Wie viele Jahre leidet Ihr Vater an Bluthochdruck?
Ich kann es nicht sagen.
Auch schon länger.
Aber lebt Ihr Eltern noch?
Ja, ich habe einen Bruder.
Ist er gesund?
Ja, er ist gesund.
Er ist ordentlicher.
Herr Becker, was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Feuerwehrmann.
Ich habe zwei Kinder.
Sie sind gesund.
Danke.
Ich habe zwei Kinder.
Sie sind gesund.
Vielen Dank.
Ich habe zwei Kinder.
Ich bin gesund.
Okay, wohnen Sie mit Ihrer Familie zusammen?
Genau, meiner Frau und die zwei Kindern, wohnen wir zusammen.
Okay.
Örbeke, rachen Sie?
Nein, ich schaue nicht.
Hatten Sie in Vergangenheit geraucht?
Nein, ich habe, kann man nicht sagen, nein.
Trinken Sie regiermäßig Alkohol?
Alkohol, ja.
Elegentlich trink ich meine Flasche Bier.
Hatten Sie schon mal Kontakt mit Drogen?
Oh, Drogen, nein, habe ich nicht gehabt.
Okay, hör, Örbeke, ich bin mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Haben Sie Fragen oder wollen Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja Doktor, wie geht es weiter? Was habe ich denn und was passiert jetzt noch mit mir?
Können Sie etwas sagen?
Ja, hör, Örbeke, mein Verdachtdiagnost ist eine lindendwirbel-Säule,
Bandscheibenvorfall, aber das ist ein Verdachtdiagnost.
Deswegen sollte ich einige Untersuchungen durchführen.
Söers werde ich Sie ausführlich untersuchen,
danach die operative Untersuchungen wird durchgeführt.
Was meinst du mit operative?
Ja, das ist anderen Untersuchungen wie Kernspintomografie oder wie Röntgen.
Und auch Ultraschall, das sind alle operative Untersuchungen.
Aber ich würde gerne Sie erste Magnetikresonanz-Tomografie veranlasen.
Okay, ist das gefährlich?
Nein, das ist nicht gefährlich.
Und das ist strahlenfrei.
Und das ist eine moderne Untersuchung.
Sie sollten auf einer Lege liegen und eine Röschung gehen.
Und mit dieser Methode können wir alle Bandscheiben gut sehen.
Was ist eine Röschung?
Sie meinen vielleicht eine Röhre.
Man kommt in eine Röhre rein.
Das ist eine Röhre.
Und durch diese Untersuchung können wir alle Gewerbe und Knöpfe gut sehen.
Und eine Diagnose feststellen.
Das ist wie ein starkes Magnetsfeld.
Und diese Magnetsfeld werden eine Magnetschall in ihre Gewerbeorgane gesendet.
Aber das ist ein starkes Geräusch.
Sie sollten eine Kopper tragen.
Und bei ihnen sollte keine Metalle, Apparete oder Metall mitbringen.
Wenn sie in der Maschine Angst haben,
weil es ihnen ein bisschen zu eng oder zu laut wird,
dann wird das Verfahren abgebrochen und die Röhre verlassen.
Ich habe keine Probleme mit der Röhre.
Ich habe einen Kollegen, der mir fragt.
Sie haben sich nicht verstanden,
dass sie sich nicht verstanden haben.
Ich würde sagen, dass sie sich nicht verstanden haben.
Sie haben sich vorher angewashbert.
Sie haben sich vorhin verstanden, dass sie nicht verstanden haben.
Sie haben sich verstanden, dass sie nicht verstanden haben.
Sie haben sich verstanden.
Ich würde gerne Sie unsere neue Patienten vorstellen.
Habt ihr sie seit?
Ja bitte.
Ja. Ich habe heute 52 jahre Patienten aufgenommen,
der Boris Becker heißt.
Der Patient stellte bei uns wegen seit 3 Wochen bestehender
Lombar,
seine Dischenmerzen schlimm geworden.
Die Schmerzen sind immer in den Lombarbereich
und die nicht irgendeinem wohin nicht traut aus.
Er berichtete, dass er zwei oder drei Tage über Profen eingenommen habe.
Aber das habe ihnen nicht ein bisschen geholfen.
Er berichtete, dass er die Intensität der Schmerzen bei acht von zehn auf dem Schmerzkala
verlegt hat.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unauffällig.
Hat der Traumplatz gefühlt?
Nein.
Er berichtete, dass er keine Parasitie oder Urinprobleme hat.
Nur Muskelnprobleme wie?
Nur Muskeln, die wirbelbogen Gelenke, die kann man auch in eine Überlastung kommen.
Nur Muskelverspannung.
Nur Muskeln, die kann man auch in eine Überlastung kommen.
Entzündungshermer ist, weil immer meistens an der Karosserie vom Körper meistens immer eine Reizentzündung
entsteht und dadurch auch die Schmerzen da sind und wenn man nur zum Beispiel Novalgin oder nur
Morphinepräparate geben würde, würde man gegenüber die Entzündung, die Reizentzündung,
nicht therapieren. Deswegen ist es so, dass unsere Basis-Medikament, was die Internisten nicht so mögen,
ist immer NSRR. Und dann, wenn es nicht ausreicht, kann man noch dazu die anderen Medikamenten
empfehlen sozusagen. Und dann natürlich gehört dazu, damit die Beweglichkeit und die Verspannung
der Muskulatur wiederhergestellt wird, würde man dann Physiotherapeutin-Gymnastik durchführen lassen.
Und Massagen und Thermotherapien und so weiter. Okay, gut. Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Vielen Dank. Haben Sie Fragen? Ich habe keine Frage, vielen Dank. Gibt es in der Gruppe noch eine Frage?